We are going to go back to the phones at 6
1 7 8 3 0 47 50 after a brief reset of the
entire thing.
Let me go to my friend Witherow from the 8
0 6 area code, Patrick OWSA Amiga.
All Mr. Pakman, your story?
Yeah.
And, you know, we, uh, we we and we we needed
on this.
Qamar sorry.
I'm calling from Texas, you know.
You know, Pedro, you know, I know what's going
on with you.
You were pretending to be Colombian, but you
speak with a not Colombian accent in Spanish.
It's so unusual.
All you know, Mr. Blackman, that's why I wanted
to call you today, you know.
Yeah, I have.
Well, I wanted to talk about, you know, I
had a question for you.
Or I had some evidence that I'm from Colombia,
you know?
Yeah.
How did you develop this accent?
Because no one in Colombia speaks the way
you speak Spanish.
Oh, you know, this is how my family talks.
You know, we're from Colombia.
You know, I grew up around some Mexicans.
Do you know they came to Colombia?
Yeah.
Would you be willing to let me in?
Sure, Pedro.
What you look like.
All you can do that would be great if you
give me a yeah, I can do roughly.
But anyway, the evidence I had, you know,
I found my my birth certificate, you know.
I have whole.
I'm actually holding Eric right now, you know.
So, yeah, it says, you know, I'm from Colombia,
has my name.
Can you actually read it for me?
Just start reading the birth certificate for
me.
Oh, you know, it's kind of boring or, you
know, but without that, I would love it and
I'm sure it's in Spanish because you're Colombian,
right?
Just start reading it.
It must be right in front of you.
OK.
You know, I can try to read you, please.
I did enough.
Your viewers wanted to listen to me.
You know, read a version.
Trust me, they can also.
Okay.
You know, okay, well, this is a little.
Longyear.
And then I have the day I was born and it
has my mom's name.
You're pretty good.
And then how you're my God.
OK.
Now, honestly, are you an American guy?
Oh, no, no, no, on.
Well, I am American.
Now, you know, but you were born in the US.
Right.
Long colonial Mr. Crane.
That's why I have my birth certificate and
your birth certificate says Bizzaro Columbia.
That's all it says.
Well, they have my parents and my.
And the day I was born to you and I just like
a normal birth certificate.
And, you know, I also have my my my my my
son banditti to have his birth certificate
here, you know?
And where was he?
Has me and my.
Oh, that's so.
He was actually born here, but he was born
here in between the time we were moving from
Colombia to the United States.
Right.
So you said you were where you were from.
Keep, though, in Colombia.
Right.
Oh, yes.
In your capital, call it Omnia.
Yeah.
All right, Pedro.
That's obviously not the capital.
We're going to let you go some day.
We will find out the truth about Pedro.
I find him endlessly entertaining.
But
you
know what?
What
can
you do?